foreign
if Islam is religion of Peace we debated
single parent households versus two
parent households we talked about
transgenderism so very intense hot fun
topics The Forbidden courses like summer
program is a one week program and
essentially we had one core course core
course excuse me that we took in the
program and that was supplemented with a
bunch of different other activities and
the other supplemental activities were
like we had academic ones we had super
social ones so I took a class on
critical thinking and like freedom of
expression for my unheard CLE who just
has an incredible Story We essentially
learned a bunch of different logical
fallacies and Jon Stewart Mills and on
Liberty the main course that I took was
taught by Kathleen stock and it was
called uh varieties of feminism how it's
changed over time and we would discuss
kind of the pros and cons of each and
and how and maybe even conjecture about
why it changed the way it did my main
class at met like every morning it was
with Thomas Chatterton Williams he was
teaching a class on black male
autobiography in the United States in
the history of blackmail experience from
our founding and so in that course we
delved into readings from like Frederick
Douglass to all people like James
Baldwin
um and yeah and so that was like the
main morning section of the course and
then every afternoon we would gather for
smaller seminars and workshops with
people ranging from uh Joshua Katz from
Princeton to the CEO of Marvel and it
was very cool to I guess like see the
intersections of politics and philosophy
and economics but also like
entrepreneurial adventures and how the
two are actually like quite uh connected
and so the centers are really cool to
try and just like I guess synthesize we
learned in the classroom in a more like
real world application there was one
taught by David Mamet he was just sort
of telling us about his experience
working as like a writer and a
playwright and then to some extent how
like being more conservative affected
his standing and that kind of social
world and and
um how it affected his art Peter
begosian taught several of his like
Street epistemology lectures that was
sort of about how to have very difficult
conversations with people in an actually
productive way and and things you can do
to get people to change their minds and
so he would like pull people out of the
audience and have them take a position
on a given sort of controversial issue
and then ask them questions and get them
to ask each other questions in a way
that was just meant to bring everyone
towards more of a consensus there were
definitely a lot of contentious issues
that you feel like you can't discuss at
universities that we were very open to
discussing so I think people had a
certain level of openness to talk about
issues that are you know maybe
really censored from the left for
example
um at the institution so like we did
feel
as if things were
less biased towards the left which I
guess would make them more biased to the
right but I think the goal was not to do
that and I think the goal was was
achieved in my opinion so each session
had 40 students there were four courses
per session so around 10 students per
course it ranged from students who had
just graduated high school so they were
incoming freshmen
um all the way to like graduate students
I was really surprised and impressed by
the amount of FaceTime we got in the
amount of one-on-one time we got with a
lot of the faculty members specifically
at lunch every single day the professors
would sit with us oftentimes you'd see
you know groups of students huddled
around Neil Ferguson for example they
talked about world history and another
group of students huddled around off
Henderson talking about social
psychology I was really drawn to their
uh to the University of Austin's
emphasis on on civil discourse and free
speech and the pursuit of truth but they
were super unique in their dedication
and like in their construction of a
curriculum around those ideals and it's
not something I've seen elsewhere in
terms of summer programs with the
university is striving to be if I'm not
mistaken is not to combat political bias
in One Direction by coming from it from
the other direction but rather to to
eradicate political buys whatsoever
their approach of Classical liberalism
worked well in opening dialogue there
were so many different kinds of people
there like atheists and Christians and
Republicans and Democrats and
Libertarians and just every kind of
person
was there and and had things to say so
discussing anything
turned into this really rich learning
experience the founder piano canelos
definitely like insists on the
importance of Beauty and the importance
of like one's environment in which they
learn and how that contributes to the
process of discovery and the pursuit of
knowledge and I think
we were yeah we were in the old Parkland
campus in Dallas which won't be the
permanent home of the University but it
was the temporary location for the
summer program it was like one of the
earliest versions of the Magna Carta in
there like the fire
entire room that I think was dedicated
to like Thomas Jefferson was supposed to
look like Monticello it's very beautiful
and it's also quite small and so it did
feel like we were kind of immersed in a
really gorgeous College